hello everyone I haven't really shown
you any kappa blanka games yet on my
channel other than the two games he lost
against the Sultan Khan against the
Mikhail Botvinnik
but this is quite undeserving for such a
player as he was one of the greatest
players to ever play the game
people often said that when he played
Capablanca you didn't actually play
against him II played against his coat
because he was never actually at the
table he was always somewhere playing
bridge or you know flirting with women
and when you made your move he just you
know came passing by and he made his
move and then he left again so his he
was the well known for his cosmic speed
of perception and you know of his
instant moves and he was one of the
greatest endgame players also to ever
play and people often tease couple Punk
about this they said okay okay I mean
what good is it to you if you can beat
anyone in the world you know even even
with unimaginable results if it's a
boring game so here in the ncover bank i
played played an interesting game just
to show that he can even though he
thought it was useless he said that the
best way to win a chess game is the
simplest way to win a chess game you
know without too many complications he
said that if you complicate a chess game
you don't understand chess and Kapil
Wonka actually has a streak of eight
years of being undefeated in tournament
games and this is including his
tournament match against the manual
after he lose one game although the
match was supposed to be 24 games Lasker
resigned after 14 games because it was
stand Rosen for wind for casablanca and
another interesting thing that kappa
blanka never actually challenged the
Lasker for the championship title
Lasker gave up the title and then Lasker
challenged kappa blanka
as Lasker was the Challenger and
Capablanca was already a champion when
they when they played their match
because Lasker was pretty sure that he
would lose to the great Cuban so yeah I
mean there are a lot of things to say
about Capablanca but I will leave
something for another video so let's see
this game this game kappa blanka is
playing against I forgot the guy's name
let me just check it again
mark phoner off and Mark Farner off was
was an arts professor a musician and he
was a pretty strong player as you'll see
Capablanca was a white and Mark Farner
of was black we have E 4 P 5 Knight to
f3 Knight to c6 and D for the scotch
game we have D 6 mask after I mean
Knight c3 Knight to f6 and Bishop to b5
by kappa blanka we have griffith to d7
casablanca castles Bishop to e7 just
developing rook to e1 and here mark
captures ink after sandy for we can't
really castle if you castles he would
lose upon to this simple variant C so
after a couple bunkers rook e1 he
decides to play eek after son before and
go for a series of trade here we have 9
chapters on d4 Knight chapters on d4
clean capture some d4 basic capture some
b5 nicely after some b5 and here a mark
phoner of finally castles and okay he
did manage to exchange a couple of
pieces and couple bunker plays Queen to
c3 attacking that c7 point we have c6
nice to be 4 by kappa blanka and here
kappa blanka is preparing Knight to f5
this is a very nice square for tonight
and also will threaten the g7 and
caresses bishop on e7 so mark plays
Knight to d7 disregarding this is a
threat and couple Blanc of course plays
Knight to a5 and he always has Bishop to
f6 with a temple on the Queen and the
cup of Blanca plays Queen to g3 now with
ideas of Queen g7 is something were to
happen to this Bishop and also some
tricks with Knight h6 so we have
tonight's the e5 we have fish up to f4
and the Queen to c7
the queen is still guarding this pawn
and this night as well and is preparing
drug to d8 and here cup of Blanco plays
rook a to d1 and rook a to d8 is simply
defending but he misses Casablancas next
move
come on plays rook captures on d6
because this phone was actually
protecting this knight on e5 so he
captures the rook rook captures on d6
and now Polanco plays Bishop to
five with a double attack with a triple
attack on this rook and if the rook
moves then well the Queen is behind the
rook and Mark Farner have actually had a
pretty good move here he had Queen a5
although he missed this with an attack
on couple bunkers rook anyone so I mean
this has to be defendant so couple luck
would probably have to play something
like Bishop to c3 and after Bishop
captures beat captures rook to g6
defending checkmate on g7 couple Blanca
was a windbag the exchange in 97 check
Kia chase Knight captures here and after
H captors on g6 couple Lanka would be
half upon but this a to pawn isn't
really a very healthy pawn so I think
Mark Toner would have some drawing
chances although he would probably still
lose the game but after Bishop to e5
Mark Farner found a brilliant move and
well he thought it was a brilliant
moving he played rook to d1 and now this
is of course very dangerous if
Capablanca captures is queen then well
it's pretty pretty simple recaptures
anyone is checkmate so couple bunker
says okay I'll capture rook and here we
have Bishop captures on e5 we're gonna
tack on the Queen and after the Queen
moves a Mark Farner of thought that well
if the queen is in protecting h2 I'll
just grab h2 woods check and if the
Queen plays something like Queen h3 or
Queen h4 two defenders I'll simply
capture this pawn and b2 so he would
grab upon that and the position would be
what still better for white but he was
hoping but couple blank and had a
different idea and if you would like to
feel free to pause the video here and
find couple uncle's idea okay I hope I
hope you were successful and
congratulations to everyone who were
successful and those of you who just
want to see what a couple Lanka did he
actually played a very nice nice to h6
check so only move since the Kings Kent
the pawn can capture the night is engage
a and now a beautiful move again by
kappa blanka Queen captures on e5 and
this is very dangerous Weis is up a
piece now and the nice can be captured
as this pawn is pinned
and also black queen is attacked so not
a lot of things for black to do here I
mean whatever he plays the loser since
he's down a B so he captured the Queen
and here a very nice finishing blow by
Kappa Knight chapters on f7 would check
for King the king and queen and if the
knight is captured if Rose captures
knight in single route to d8 leads the
checkmate and if if a Knight captures on
f7 King to g8 in and simply Knight
captures only five and what couple Wonka
is upper piece and this is winning a
piece on the porn actually so yeah a
very very nice maneuver so after Knight
captures on f7 his his opponent marked
owner of the arts musician professor
resigned and a very nice a very nice
final final picture and a very
interesting game by kappa blanka even
though he was probably the strongest
player ever to play the game his games
weren't always that interesting although
because he was the mostly an endgame
player so yeah that's it I do hope you
enjoyed this game and I will try to to
bring up some work of couple Blancas
games and I'm glad I'm glad a lot of you
enjoyed that game by Gregory House
yesterday so yeah that's it thank you
all for watching as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here and all
season